[Music]
[Applause]
this guy wins Awards Michael wilbon ESPN
pardoned the interruption co-host and
NBA Countdown analyst joins us on the
program all right is this Michael the
journalist or Michael the Bears fan that
we're talking to right now
I I don't even know that the journalists
I think he's retired you know by the way
I know you know because I know how
well-versed you are in all kinds of you
you know that was Al Green and not Barry
White no but I wanted to be Barry White
you wanted to be Barry why Barry as
opposed to Alvin well no I couldn't I
couldn't sing like Al Green I could do
the deeper voice because Barry White
Barry White would talk to you when he
would be singing he'd be like yes he
would he would he would start every time
very good all right ladies good very
wide treatment
um I guess I gotta have the the Bears
fan I you know uh the new Bears
president in Chicago anyways my neighbor
and we know we're
you know I I think we both describe each
other as friends and I'm conflicted
about this obviously because I'm an Alum
of one but before I bled purple
um and and and went to a Big Ten school
I've been a Bears fan since I can
remember so six years old five years old
and this is an intriguing hire and I I
think um I know I'm glad which I
wouldn't be otherwise if it was the you
know Cincinnati Bengals or some other
team but because of the Bears um and
he's and he's president and CEO I'm
pretty happy for him and for the
organization okay but are you in a good
position you have the number one overall
pick
and you know the Bears are interesting
for a change yeah just because they have
this decision makes them interesting do
you keep Justin fields or do you trade
him and take Bryce young reset the
quarterback clock
I keep Justin Fields I need to reset
anything
I'm not procedural I mean you know me
long enough and well enough I don't give
a damn about that stuff
um you keep the guy who has shown you he
has something in him and I know he's got
to get better as a passer but I don't
like quarterbacks who are like the size
of
you know Kyler Murray that that's not
that ain't getting it for me okay now I
know he's bigger than that but Bryce
who's a tremendous Talent
I mean he's what is he he's a model I
don't think he could take the pounding
you see the pounding Justin Fields has
taken at six three 225 pounds
I don't want I don't want my quarterback
taking that pounding I like Justin
fields and let's use the pick let's
figure out how to attract and use that
leverage and and Surround him they got
more money than any team and they got
picks I don't want to hear any excuses
from the new Bears GM Ryan poles yeah
get it done yeah it's about scouting now
if I thought Bryce young was a franchise
quarterback uh and drastic and you know
an upgrade absolutely I would trade
Justin Fields I would get some draft
picks back and I then I've reset the
quarterback contract clock that helps us
I know we have all this money now I got
a another first round pick I send Justin
field someplace else and I get a guy who
who plays the game in a more sustainable
way Justin Fields this isn't sustainable
it's fascinating it isn't but that
that's what would worry me Mike is I I
think it's like Lamar Jackson eventually
you can see all of these injuries piling
up Cam Newton the injuries pile up it's
like first five years or six years of a
career we're like oh he's unbelievable
then all of a sudden nicked up surgery
shoulder knee ankle uh I don't know what
makes us what makes us think that's not
going to be the case I don't think he
plays that I don't think he plays that
way I think he has the ability it is in
college he has injuries in college that
Justin Fields didn't have he had well
but did you watch those Ohio State Games
nobody ever got close to the quarterback
and they had those great wide receivers
there you go and that's what the Bears
have to do
I know I'm serious that's what so he
first of all he doesn't what's your what
you're proving to me is you know he
doesn't have to play that way Justin
Fields he completed 73 percent of the
passes as a senior he can pass that we
can throw the football so get some get a
line which he didn't have true and get
and get another receiver he had two is
Rookie year but he's he's also played in
three different offensive systems in
three years let's get some stability and
some Talent around him it doesn't have
to be sustainable he doesn't have to and
should not be trying to play that way
you're a buzz kill you know we're trying
to get excitement here and have people
care about the Bears and doing something
drastic like this so so having a great
quarterback and
and you know you gotta you got to trade
the quarterback really because all the
franchises I see you having Buzz about
every day for all these years Dan there
the teams have quarterbacks nobody's
talking about when he was in his third
year trading Aaron Rodgers
nobody was talking about trading Tom
Brady I'm not saying he's going to be
great like that nobody's talking about
trading the kid uh Justin Herbert put a
good quarterback back there I need to
trade him I don't want the Bears to be a
clown show I want them to be a
professional football team uh I know you
uh since you're you're a Bears fan then
you're not used to rooting in the uh in
the playoffs so who who's your uh feel
good team
feel good but I I have for I don't know
some weeks now thought the Bengals and
Niners are the two teams that are lined
up in the Super Bowl I don't have any
problems seeing Philadelphia the the one
seeds you know Philadelphia Kansas City
I don't think there's any argument
against them I just think that the
Bengals and Niners okay are the teams
that I I think you know speaking of at
least one of those teams having a
quarterback nobody wants to trade for
other picks Joe burrow
um I just I just think those teams
really if you if you give me a
championship game in each one of those
conferences Kansas City Cincinnati we've
seen Cincinnati beat them
um and and Niners Philly I'm gonna take
the Niners but but that would those
would be good matchups but Dan I got to
tell you the playoffs don't start off
with a bang the first round
I'm looking at it you know you got two
teams you got two games that are duds
to me the Baltimore game I mean maybe
they have a 10 chance Miami has zero
percent chance of winning zero okay and
so you got two games you know right out
the box that are duds to me and I'm
looking at the playoffs going okay
people don't look at the NFL playoffs
with and they're not Discerning they
don't care they just want their football
and they'll chip or anything I get that
but I'm looking at it going ah they're
all rematches two of them are duds not
starting off with a bang the first
weekend as far as I'm concerned yeah you
got the Dolphins game they're now 13
Point dogs and uh the Ravens started out
at six and a half Point underdogs
they're now up to eight and a half we're
talking to Michael wilbon from pardon
the interruption I was watching you and
uh Mr Tony
and uh I agreed with Tony on a couple of
things what's going on with Calipari at
Kentucky and how they're treating him
also if I'm the Rams I say to Sean McVay
you make a decision here because we got
coaches who are leaving we have to run a
franchise we're not here to you know
help you get your next job you're not
Belichick we need you to tell us and if
you want to leave you want to take a
year off fine but tell us now because we
went through this last year we gave you
a contract gave you a contract extension
you owe it to us we don't owe anything
to you we owe you owe it to us to tell
us what you want to do and if you want
to sit out a year you want to do TV for
a year and come back great but tell us
now
I I would be a real short conversation
between me if I was Mr cronky and my
football coach
um McVay I would just say you in or out
today now in or out I I turn around and
walk out the door
um he seems like he's got a lot of
things potentially working he's got
something on every eye of the stove okay
but then I'd be looking for my next
coach if I'm the Los Angeles Rams brass
and there's a cow I mean with 29 locked
up on both those topics uh with Cal I
it's like as I analogize it's like a
pop-up store John Calipari can set up
shop particularly in the transfer portal
era which we're deep into
he can set up shop wherever he wants and
within a year being the NCAA tournament
within two be a threat
so I mean to hell with Kentucky
I mean you know the college football
fans college sports fans football and
basketball are the worst and it's
usually college football fans it's it's
basketball in the Bluegrass but you know
people are crazy and you know they you
know I use Nebraska as an example
yesterday they ran somebody out because
he went nine and three too often they
haven't been nine and three cents in the
last oh Frank solich I I kept thinking
remember you went to Ohio you and did
great at Ohio you with that program I'm
like Frank solitch wasn't sexy enough
for Nebraska or Nebraska thought they
were better than Frank and I I just
thought he was you know they would kill
for nine wins now Mike
of course they were for the last decade
yeah and so you know I mean Kentucky
this unbelievable it's not unbelievable
it's believable how spoiled and what
Egos and what babies as a group they are
so if I'm a cow I'd say you know what it
is my resignation how many people
wouldn't be after Calipari with an hour
he can set up a shop wherever he wants
and say I'll be at the I'll be in the
transfer portal for a week give me some
time uh I brought this up
do we have too much scoring in the NBA
are there maybe I think the NBA has
become Major League Baseball Mike that
it's home run or nothing it's a
three-pointer or nothing and it and I
while I love scoring I love offense I
never played defense in my life but
at some I don't think the game is better
I think the numbers are better I don't
think the game is better same thing with
baseball home runs are up the game is
not better in baseball yeah but you know
what it isn't Dan and of course this is
why Theo Epstein has been hired by
baseball to fix baseball because all
these things are a television show
that's what they are and the NBA decided
consciously intentionally
that defense was bad for the product and
it wasn't you know it wasn't art and
they decided they always go too far
every League goes too far the NFL I'm
not going to say the NFL went too far
because
strategically it's about health and
safety more so than the other sports but
look at the NHL scorings in a 25-year
High
the NBA into the 50-year High I mean you
got to go back to I think it's actually
60 I think it's 1963.
so I'm with you the game is not better
it's a little bit too much there's no
defense at all they've legislated it out
but the NFL did the same thing and they
all do it for one reason it's a
television show they wanted to look a
certain way on television that's where
this even though most players don't even
know this it's it's this is the primary
stream of Revenue
that makes it go it's television and so
the NBA is has sought to do that and
baseball's doing it baseball's trying to
do it they got to get action back in the
game and that's what Theo is charged
with the responsibility to task he's
charged with that they're all at the
same time trying to figure out how to be
more appealing on television and in the
process and I like I trust Theo to come
closer to getting it right personally
than others because basketball just
doesn't have there's no there's no can
you imagine I mean Charles Oakley in
today's game he would just stand on the
floor and shrug and say what is this
what are we doing here yeah
well he wouldn't have a role
no they wouldn't even bring him in they
wouldn't sign them they say look can you
put you on a 10-day you you're not a
stretch four you're a power forward
you're you're you're you're you're not
you're a stretch we're not a stretch
four I'm not sure we can have you it's
just
it's a weird thing and so Dan look
you've covered as many playoff years as
I have maybe you think there's a chance
is there some correcting that can go on
by the time we get to the middle of
April in your opinion
now
like how would they correct
start calling some start allow
a lot from the game right now that maybe
there's no correcting
but but Mike I had the commissioner on
the show a couple of weeks ago and I
said to Adam Silver
can you call carrying like how did it
get to the point where right I mean it's
egregious and you can't guard you cannot
guard anybody if they have that much
athleticism and you give them that much
of an advantage of I get to carry the
ball
yeah you know how did we get from Allen
Iverson and John Stockton carrying it to
now everybody carries it everybody
well Dan they they are cracking down
like last night just watching three or
four games sampling three or four games
there were a lot of traveling calls I
mean I saw a half
in like two hours
carrying the ball exactly calming yeah
and we used to call it the old days yeah
I'm in agreement with you so if you can
make those kinds of adjustments on the
Fly
maybe there's some hope and it look it
becomes a little bit more of a slow
dance once we get to mid-april anyway
like to see some look if you can't
defend Giannis
that he's gonna have we're gonna have
we're gonna have a bunch of 50-point
games in the playoffs as far as I'm
concerned it sounds like we're in
agreement those things are devalued
they're not like 50 point games in the
80s or the 90s or even the odds they're
not even like Kobe's 50-point games
um because there's no resistance put
forth to stop them so what the hell are
they used I mean what's the value of
them we wouldn't do well in part in the
interruption we agreed too much
Tony and I agreed on those topics
yesterday we could just be loud getting
there
doesn't have to be fun to build
disagreement we could just be loud
getting I don't even know what we're
talking about today I don't know that
we'll have topics that are as easily
agreed upon as Calipari and um
some of the NFL stuff but you know it's
just interesting I we're both old men
get off our lawn
um and I don't know that we're gonna
have a lot of disagreement Mike all else
fails talk about the Cowboys and talk
about LeBron
what Dan I don't know that we're going
to have that much disagreement on that
given what LeBron
is doing right now
um and the Cowboys we could have plenty
of disagreement I I
don't know what to make of them it's
just too much made of them we're the
we're the only show that does not come
in every day saying okay the Cowboys are
on the rundown we're not every other
show on the network is
and they'll sometimes SportsCenter will
call and say can you guys talk about the
cow and we say no we're not doing it
stop doing that yeah
well hey having been there at
SportsCenter where it felt like every
night this is you got to talk about this
you got to talk to me yes wait Duke
basketball I mean they're playing Vandy
why do we have to talk about Duke
against Mandy well coach Kelly shows you
though Dan some things can disappear
because Duke basketball
yeah it's sort of surprising
um and I don't know you know you got to
give anybody time for adjustment
um but that look we knew that was going
to be a hard follow you and I are old
enough to remember you know people two
coaches specifically and even though
their records were great trying to
follow John Wooden you I mean it's man
this is maybe it's an impossible task
it's gonna really bear watching you know
college basketball sadly I know this
must hurt you having having played it at
a real level
it's a one it's a six-week sport now Dan
Mike do you know who the favorite is do
you know who's the favorite to win the
national title
who
Houston
I you know I was gonna actually sounded
smart I guess in Houston I mean I watch
Houston play once earlier this year they
barely beat Virginia I watched them one
game
and but Dan like
we don't know I mean something that used
to be obsessive in the culture and the
sport culture if you were a sports fan
you had college basketball on your radar
not long after Christmas and it stayed
there until April 1st yes because we the
first six weeks off we knew the players
they came back for a sophomore year or
Junior yeah yeah there's that yeah just
the familiarity we've lost the
familiarity of college basketball
football you're locked in for three
years even if you transfer you're still
in the sport itself somewhere yeah we
can find you hey we can find you after
you emerge from the transfer portal are
you and Tony attached that when you
retire you both retire at the same time
have you discussed that
uh we have not
um that wasn't even on my radar for like
10 years and it's on my radar
um Tony let you know him how can he
retire if he has three days off he's
calling the producers for two of them to
suggest show topics
he can't he can't function without work
I can well I don't know I can't I don't
know if Mr Tony if you'd call that work
Mike because he's in his attic or
basement or whatever room and he's and
he's only there for 22 minutes and then
you guys are done try to no he's there
on camera for 22 minutes yeah a lot
longer but but he does do his podcast I
know that hey I would never I would
never let that job go but Mr Tony I
guess no well I love I love doing the
show every day but PTI you know if I'm
in Assisted Living I would be doing PTI
there they would be feeding me they'd
have to help feed me change my diaper
and I'm still I'd still be there doing
PTI if I could there's some people who
may suggest we're way too close to that
already but but he listen as long as he
can take a break and go play golf every
day you know then then he he probably
could do it but no it's I don't have to
I don't
I don't think I'm as tied to anything as
I was
six years ago and maybe that's because
I'm an old man chasing around a freshman
in high school who's got basketball
practices and games and AAU Dan I'm 64
years old going to AAU game I like it
and the coach will come out and you know
the visiting coach will come out and say
hey can you come over and let's have a
chat and you're here with your grandson
right and I want to swing it to God say
no
oh good to talk to you Mike uh maybe
we'll cross paths in Arizona wait are
you leaving Arizona when the Super Bowl
gets there
uh I'm I'm there because the countdown
is there all three
nights uh that week and so I'm around so
you know okay have clubs you know find
me are you allowed to go out are you
allowed to go out
that's a good question
you know Dan I would like to but I I
don't I don't know that I can
pull it off I sound like Tony now but I
I would like to you know what kind the
bad part Dan is you know that the West
is cold now I mean it's cold and rainy
cow I was in California Christmas day
okay it was 80. since then there have
been highs in like around 50 degrees it
all feels like San Francisco so I'm
hoping that stuff goes away Arizona's
been the same way I'm hoping that stuff
goes away guys let's let's all pray for
Michael wilbon prayers
he's just short of a GoFundMe come on
yeah
go f you uh not go find you yeah uh Mike
thanks for joining us as always buddy
Dan thanks for having me that's Michael
wilbon pardon the interruption take a
break we'll close up shop after this